THE CHINESE MILITARY SAYS THAT
IT SUCCESSFULLY COMPLETED ITS
MILITARY DRILLS NEAR TAIWAN.
BUT IT'S NOT LEAVING THE ISLAND
ALONE, TAIWAN'S DEFENSE
MINISTRY SAYS THAT IT'S
DETECTED 25 WARPLANES AND SIX
TRIPS AROUND THE TAIWAN STRIP
ON THURSDAY.
THIS COMES MORE THAN A WEEK
AFTER THE U.S. HOUSE SPEAKER
VISIT TO TAIWAN.
CNN'S SELINA WANG REPORTS ON
THE LINGERING TENSIONS.
>> THIS SHOW OF FORCE WAS MADE
FOR TV.
CHINESE SOLDIERS PREPARING FOR
BATTLE.
WARPLANES FLOODING THE SKIES,
DESTROYERS IN CIRCLING THE
WATERS AROUND TAIWAN.
U.S. HOUSE SPEAKER, NANCY
PELOSI WAS IN TAIWAN FOR LESS
THAN 24 HOURS.
BUT BEIJING'S MILITARY DRILLS
IN RESPONSE ARE LASTING FOUR
DAYS.
>> NANCY PELOSI'S VISIT,
ACTUALLY I SEE IT AS A GIFT TO
PRESIDENT XI JINPING BECAUSE HE
CAN USE THAT TO UNITE THE
PEOPLE.
THE FORMER VISIT OUTRAGE WAS
BOOMING IN CHINA OVER COVID
LOCKDOWNS IN ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION FROM CHANGING
SPITTING ZERO COVID POLICY.
EVER SINCE NEWS OF PELOSI'S
POLICY, LEAD PROPAGANDA HAS
BEEN IN OVERDRIVE AND
CAPTIVATING THE NATION.
THE PROMINENT VOICES EVEN
SUGGESTED CHINA SHOULD SHOULD
THE PLANE DOWN.
THE COUNTRY RALLYING BEHIND
BEIJING THAT PELOSI'S VISIT IS
A DIRECT CHALLENGE TO CHINA'S
SOVEREIGNTY.
EVEN THOUGH THE COMMUNIST PARTY
HAS NEVER ROLLED OVER TAIWAN
PEOPLE IN TEN ARE TAUGHT FROM
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL THAT TAIWAN
IS PART OF THE MOTHERLAND AND
COMMUNICATION IS ONLY A MATTER
OF TIME.
THE NIGHT OF PELOSI'S VISIT,
MILLION OF PEOPLE IN CHINA
TRACK THEIR FLIGHT IN REALTIME,
WAITING TO SEE IF THE MILITARY
WOULD INTERVENE.
WHEN SHE LANDED SAFELY, THE
MOST HARD-CORE PREACHY HEADS
WERE DISAPPOINTED AND SOME EVEN
BREAKING INTO TEARS AT THE
STATE MEDIA HAD LIED TO THEM
ABOUT THE UNPRECEDENTED
MEASURES BEIJING WOULD TAKE TO
STOP HER.
BUT THE MILITARY BILLS THAT
FOLLOWED PROVED TO BE MORE
PROVOCATIVE THAN BEFORE.
SHOOTING ROCKETS TOWARDS TAIWAN
HISTORY AND OVER THE ISLAND FOR
THE FIRST TIME.
CHINESE WARPLANES FLEW EVER
CLOSER TO TAIWAN AND IN GREATER
NUMBERS THIS TIME.
AND CIRCLING THE ISLAND IN THE
PRACTICE BLOCKADE, AND WELL THE
MOOD IN CHINA QUICKLY CHANGED.
SOME EVEN STARTED THANKING
PELOSI ON CHINA'S TWITTER LIKE
PLATFORM.
ONE, WROTE THE UNIFICATION OF
THE MOTHERLAND WILL SOON BE
REALIZED, THANKS PELOSI FOR
YOUR HELPING HAND.
THEY PROVIDED A LOT MORE
BENEFIT BECAUSE THEY USED IT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY AND TO
DEMONSTRATE POWER.
THE MILITARY POWER AND PROVIDED
POLITICAL AMMUNITION THAT XI
JINPING NEEDS TO SOLIDIFY.
>> XI JINPING MAY HAVE TURNED
THEIR CRISIS INTO THEIR
ADVANTAGE AT HOME.
BUT IT BROUGHT HIS FURTHER
ANTAGONIZE THE.
U.S. AND INCREASE TAIWAN'S
RESENTMENT TOWARDS THE
MAINLAND.
SELINA WANG, CNN BEIJING.